-As I said,
today is Thanksgiving.
It's a day that --
all about giving thanks,
so I thought, what better day
to write up my weekly
Thank You Notes?
Do you guys mind?
[ Cheers and applause ]
James, can I get some
Thank You Note writing music,
please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Look. He's eating something.
-Oh, my gosh.
-He's eating leftovers.
-Yeah.
It's a turkey leg.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you, gravy boats,
for looking like
I'm about to summon a genie
with high cholesterol.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, turkey,
or as I like to call you,
savory Ambien.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, pecan pie,
for always starting
a spirited Thanksgiving argument
about how to properly
pronounce your name.
"It's pih-CON."
[ Applause ]
"It's pih-CAN pie-EE."
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, adding a leaf
to the dining table,
for making sure
I'm not the only thing
getting wider on Thanksgiving.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, person who brings
salad to Thanksgiving dinner.
We aren't gonna say
anything to your face,
but you best believe
you're getting dragged
in the group chat as we speak.
"Salad?"
[ Applause ]
-"Are you kidding?"
-"You gotta be kidding."
♪♪
Thank you, squash,
for looking like a pumpkin
that's sucking in its gut
for a selfie.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Black Friday sales,
or as I like to call you,
"The Purge: Walmart Edition."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my Thank You Notes.